SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, ANOTHER 12
TO 24 INCHES EXPECTED TODAY.
WE DO BEGIN, THOUGH, IN UKRAINE
WHERE 48 CHILDREN ARE AMONG THE
THOUSANDS STILL TRAPPED IN THE
CITY OF BAKHMUT AS WAR RAGES ALL
AROUND THEM.
OFFICIALS SAY THEY ARE URGING
EVERYONE TO GET OUT, BUT SOME
ARE IN AREAS THAT ARE NO LONGER
ACCESSIBLE.
>> CNN'S ALEX MARQUARDT IS IN
EASTERN UKRAINE THIS MORNING.
GIVE US A SENSE WHAT IS THE
REALITY THERE IN AND AROUND
BAKHMUT AT THIS HOUR?
>> Reporter: WELL, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS HAVE LEFT
BAKHMUT BUT IT IS JUST
EXTRAORDINARY TO THINK THERE ARE
STILL THAT MANY CIVILIANS IN THE
CITY.
THAT CITY HAS JUST BEEN
PULVERIZED.
IT IS THE SITE OF THE TIERSEST
FIGHTING IN THE COUNTRY
ACCORDING TO PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
AND TOP MILITARY COMMANDERS.
UKRAINIAN FORCES APPEAR TO BE ON
THEIR HEELS AS RUSSIAN FORCES
PRESS FORWARD.
THERE HAS BEEN NO DECISION
WHETHER TO PULL BACK BY THE
UKRAINIANS, WHETHER TO SURRENDER
THE CITY ACCORDING TO A MILITARY
SPOKESMAN IN THIS PART OF THE
COUNTRY, BUT THE RUSSIANS DO
APPEAR TO BE TRYING TO ENCIRCLE
THE CITY, THEY HAVE TAKEN SOME
AREAS NORTH OF BAKHMUT.
THOSE FORCES HAVE BEEN PRIMARILY
MADE UP OF THOSE MERCENARIES AND
CONVICTS FOR THE PAST FEW MONTHS
LEADING THAT FIGHT, THEY HAVE
BEEN BACKED UP BY REGULAR
RUSSIAN FORCES.
NOW THE UKRAINIANS SAY THAT
THESE ARE THE TOP FIGHTERS THAT
ARE LEADING THIS PUSH.
WE DID HEAR FROM AN UKRAINIAN
SOLDIER YESTERDAY WHO SAID
DESPITE THE DIRE PICTURE PAINTED
BY UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS THE
ACTUAL SITUATION IS 100% WORSE.
SO UKRAINE TRYING TO HOLD ON AS
THEIR DEFENSIVE POSITIONS GET
PUMMELED.
IF RUSSIA WERE TO TAKE THE CITY
IT WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
VICTORY AS YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FIGHT FOR
BAKHMUT FOR MONTHS NOW, IT WOULD
BE A BOOST FOR RUSSIA, A REAL
BLOW FOR UKRAINE.
BOTH SIDES HAVE LOST THOUSANDS
OF MEN.
IT WOULD GIVE RUSSIA ANOTHER
FOOT HOLD HERE IN THE DONBAS, IN
EASTERN UKRAINE, BUT UKRAINE
WILL TRY TO MAKE THAT AS MUCH OF
A SYMBOLIC VICTORY AS THEY CAN
RATHER THAN A STRATEGIC VICTORY.
IF RUSSIA WERE TO PUSH THEM OUT
UKRAINE WOULD DIGS IN JUST TO
THE WEST OF THE CITY AND AT THIS
POINT IN THIS VERY BLOODY
FIGHTING THEY ARE TRYING TO
WEAKEN THE RUSSIAN FORCES AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE SO THAT EVEN IF
THEY DID TAKE THE CITY, THAT
THERE WOULDN'T BE IN ANY KIND OF
CONDITION TO PRESS FORWARD AFTER
THAT.
BUT THE FIGHT IS STILL VERY MUCH
ONGOING, RUSSIANS TRYING TO
STAND THEIR GROUND.
JIM AND ERICA?
>> ALEX MARQUARDT, THANKS SO
MUCH.
>>> JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS
RETIRED U.S. ARMY MAJOR MIKE
LYONS.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON.
THANKS FOR FAKING THE TIME THIS
MORNING.
>> HEY, JIM.
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
>> YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS
BATTLEFIELD CLOSELY.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS SAY THEY
HAVE NOT YET MADE A DECISION TO
PULL BACK FROM BAKHMUT, THEY ARE
CLEARLY PLACING A LOT OF
IMPORTANCE ON THIS.
THERE IS A VIEW THAT THERE MIGHT
BE ROOM FOR STRATEGIC RETREAT AS
IT WERE.
WHAT'S YOUR VIEW?
SHOULD THEY HOLD THAT GROUND?
IS IT WORTH THE PRICE THEY'RE
PAYING?
>> WELL, THERE IS NOT A LOT OF
EVADE WHILE THE ENEMY IS STRONG
AND UKRAINE HAS TO TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT THAT.
THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN IN THIS FIGHT
GIVEN THE FACT THEY WILL HAVE TO
BE DEPLOYED SOMEPLACE ELSE.
BAKHMUT DOES NOT HOLD ANY
STRATEGIC VALUE ON THE GROUND
REALLY AND THEY HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THEIR FORCES ARE BETTER
USED ELSEWHERE AT THIS POINT.
IT'S A HARD DECISION, LIKELY TO
TAKE, AND IT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY MEAN RETREAT OR A
LOSS AND LET RUSSIA DO WHAT IT
WANTS WITH IT, BUT IT'S MORE OF
AN EVADE WHEN IT ENEMY IS
STRONG.
THEY HAVE A LOT MORE OF THAT
FIREPOWER.
>> WE WERE BACK ONCE AGAIN IN A
SPACE WE'VE BEEN MANY TIMES
SINCE THE START OF THIS WAR MORE
THAN A YEAR AGO AND THAT IS A
NEW WEAPONS SYSTEM IS GOING IN,
A CAPABLE ONE, IN THIS CASE
TANKS SUCH AS THE LEE PARDONS
AND THE U.S. MADE ABRAMS TANKS
BUT THE FOCUS IS ANOTHER WEAPONS
SYSTEM, THIS ONE THE F-16 WHICH
U.S. OFFICIALS HAVE SAID SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE WAR THAT
THAT'S NOT THE WEAPON THAT
UKRAINIAN FORCES REALLY NEED
RIGHT NOW.
I WONDER DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
ASSESSMENT OR SHOULD THE U.S.
AND ITS PARTNERS SEND THEM IN?
>> NO, I DO AGREE WITH THAT.
I THINK APPLYING F-16s TO THE
BATTLEFIELD RIGHT NOW
IMMEDIATELY, FIRST OF ALL, JUST
COULDN'T HAPPEN, IT WOULD TAKE
NINE MONTHS TO A YEAR TO TRAIN
UKRAINIAN PILOTS TO FLY THEM AND
TO COORDINATE A COMBINED ARMS
BATTLEFIELD WITH TANKS AND
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS AND
INFANTRY ON THE GROUND WOULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT.
THE F-16s, THOUGH, GIVE UKRAINE
ATTACK CAPABILITY INSIDE OF
RUSSIA.
IN THIS WAR OF ATTRITION RIGHT
NOW THE SIDE THAT WINS ATTACKS
THE OTHER SIDE'S CAPABILITY TO
WAGE WAR.
RIGHT NOW UKRAINE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT CAPABILITY.
RUSSIA DOES.
RUSSIA IS INSIDE UKRAINE AND IS
ATTACKING THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO THE F-16s WHILE THEY MIGHT
SOLVE A PROBLEM IN THE SHORT
TERM, IF THEY'RE THERE RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE JUST NOT GOING TO GET
THERE ON TIME AND I JUST DON'T
BELIEVE THEY WILL HAVE ANY
IMPACT ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT NATO
EXPANSION LAST JUNE, WE WERE IN
MADRID AS NATO ANNOUNCED THE
ACCESSION OR THEIR SUPPORT,
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT OF FINLAND AND
SWEDEN JOINING.
SINCE THEN TURKEY HAS AGAIN
STOOD IN THE WAY, TURK I DIDN'T
AND HUNGARY OF SWEDEN'S
ACCESSION.
FINLAND IS PREPARING TO TAKE
STEPS FORWARD.
DO YOU THINK IT IS SMART TO
SPLIT THE TWO?
START WITH FINLAND, POSSIBLY
MOVE ON TO SWEDEN IF THE TURKISH
OR HUNGARIANS ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN OR IS IT BETTER FOR THEM
TO GO TOGETHER?
>> I THINK IT'S BETTER FOR THEM
TO GO TOGETHER.
NATO HAS TO BE STRONG HERE.
THE TURKS HAVE A NUMBER,
WHATEVER THAT NUMBER IS THAT
THEY WANT CONCESSIONS TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN, THAT'S THE DOWN SIDE OF
THE ALLIANCE AND THE FACT THAT
EACH NATO COUNTRY HAS TO APPROVE
ACCEPTANCE INTO IT.
I WAS NEVER ONE FOR BRINGING
ACTUALLY A LOT OF THOSE NATO
COUNTRIES THAT ARE CLOSE TO
RUSSIA INTO NATO IN THE PAST
BECAUSE WE CAN'T HAVE MEMBERSHIP
TO NATO TO BE EVERYBODY BUT
RUSSIA IN EUROPE BECAUSE THAT
CREATES THE SAME PROBLEM WE HAD
DURING THE FIRST WORLD WAR AND
THAT'S WHAT RUSSIA -- ONE OF
RUSSIA'S STICKING POINTS TO BE,
BUT NOW THE SITUATION HAS
CHANGED ON THE GROUND, I THINK
THAT BOTH OF THEM NEED TO GO IN
AT THE SAME TIME, THE ALLIANCE
HAS GOT TO BE STRONG.
AND THEN EVENTUALLY NOW I COULD
EVEN SEE GO FIVE YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD, ONCE THERE IS A PEACE
SETTLEMENT THAT UKRAINE DOES GET
MORE SECURITY ASSURANCES FROM
NATO EVENTUALLY AND MAYBE